[موسيقى]
لا
الكل
معذرة كنت أظن أننا ذاهبون
لديك هذا السؤال
لأكون صادقًا جدًا معك
تحدثنا مع صباح اليوم
الشركة المنظمة للرحلة
قطار لمعرفة ما إذا كنا لا نستطيع
التحرك في يخت رملي
[موسيقى]
لك
سابقًا
التي سأخبركم بها عن نكتة
صدر الذوق السيئ أمس
حتى لو كنت أحب الدعابة ومن
المهم بالنسبة لي
الفكاهة لكني أدركت ذلك
في النهاية كانت مزحة سيئة
تذوق في موضوع حساس للغاية
ورأيت النسب التي لديها
أخذ أول شيء سأذهب إليك
أن نقول هو أننا هنا في باريس سان جيرمان لسنا كذلك
فوق الأرض
أن النادي ككل
اللاعبين والموظفين كل شخص أنت
إيلاء اهتمام وثيق ، بطبيعة الحال ، لمشكلة
المناخ وذلك تحت أي ظرف من الظروف
لا نفعل أي شيء لدي بأي حال من الأحوال
سمعت الكثير من الأشياء والساعات
أمس المكالمات
يعترف اليوم حتى لو حاولت
لمواصلة التركيز على اللعبة
لا داعي للاعتذار
نكتة سيئة الذوق
لكن صدقوني في النادي ، ها نحن ذا
نتأثر جميعًا بهذه المشاكل
المناخ هنا